what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down the entire
plot of chainsaw man in 15 minutes or
less covering all the main events of the
manga from beginning to end before we
get into it though if you want to see
more content from this particular series
then be sure to hit that like button and
as always don't forget to sub for more
anime and manga videos like this
okay so the story of chainsaw man takes
place in 1997 in a world where devils
exist alongside humanity every devil has
its own unique powers as they each
represent something that humans are
afraid of for example the fox devil
represents fear of foxes while the
future devil represents fear of the
future basically anything humans fear in
any way will manifest itself as a devil
and the more people are afraid of
something the more powerful that devil
will be
this brings us to the beginning of
chainsaw man as it follows a young devil
hunter named denji who's being forced to
work for the yakuza when denji was a kid
his dad owed the yakuza a massive debt
and after his dad died this old man
threatened to kill denji unless he found
a way to pay ever since then he's been
killing devils which are sold by the
yakuza on the black market and he does
this with the help of his trusty
chainsaw devil called pachita these two
have had a contract ever since denji was
young but because of the debt they both
live in extreme poverty and barely have
enough money to survive
anyway one day the old man brings them
to this devil hunting job in an
abandoned warehouse but it turns out to
be an ambush as they're brutally
attacked from behind the reason for this
betrayal was that the yakuza tried to
get stronger by making a contract with
the zombie devil and this devil in
particular had a special hatred for
devil hunters that's why this army of
yakuza zombies slice them up before
dumping their remains in the trash and
inside this dumpster is when a bit of
dengi's blood trickles down into
pachita's mouth it's the rule in this
series that devils can heal themselves
by drinking blood as so buchita gains
enough strength to form a brand new
contract this contract states that in
exchange for receiving the heart of a
devil dengue himself needs to go on and
live a normal life which is something
they always used to dream about soon
after this he's fully revived but this
time around with a chord coming out of
his chest and by pulling the chord
that's how he turns into chainsaw man he
then proceeds to tear apart the entire
horde of yakuza zombies as well as
killing the zombie devil itself and this
is when the public safety devil hunters
arrive among them is makima who's one of
the highest ranking devil hunters in
japan and after seeing what denji can do
she persuades him to take a job with the
government from there he joins tokyo
special division 4 which is an
experimental group of devil hunters that
includes aki who's this serious looking
guy here and power who's a special type
of devil known as a fiend fiends are
devils that have completely taken over
the dead body of a human which is
different from devil hybrids who are
humans that can choose to turn into a
devil if they want to
in any case at first denji doesn't get
along with either of them as aki tries
to get him to quit while power betrays
him and nearly gets him eaten by the bat
devil but despite that makima pulls some
strings so that the three of them start
living together in the process denji
gets to live his dream of being normal
as he gets to eat regular food and do
other normal things that he couldn't do
before meanwhile at work he continues to
develop a crush on makima and using that
to her advantage she promises to grant
denji any wish if he can kill the gun
devil this devil is one of the strongest
to appear in history and 13 years ago it
wiped out over a million people
including aki's family since that day
it's never been seen again and the first
step to finding it is to collect these
small pieces of gun devil flesh that
were left behind from its previous
attack this quest to find more pieces is
partly why division 4 is sent on a
mission to a hotel where they encounter
the eternity devil during this fight the
eternity devil traps them in a single
moment in time but it promises to
release them if they allow it to have
chainsaw man's heart gradually this
causes nearly everyone in the group to
try and sacrifice denji but aki saves
him as he believes that he'll be useful
in taking down the gun chainsaw man then
repays the favor by fighting the
eternity devil for three days straight
and he puts it through so much agony
that eventually it gives up and allows
itself to be killed
after its death they find a missing gun
devil piece inside it because by
consuming these bullets weaker devils
are able to make themselves more
powerful
anyhow later that same week the hall of
special division four meet up for drinks
and during the conversation it's implied
that mackieman knows why the devil
wanted denji's heart the next day she
heads off on a trip to request
assistance for him but on the journey
she and her partner are ambushed by
assassins who shoot them both
across tokyo agents from divisions 1 2 3
and 4 are ambushed as well with the
assassin targeting denji being another
devil hybrid this katana man claims that
he was sent by the gun devil to steal
chainsaws hard but on a personal level
he also wants revenge for his
grandfather who was sliced to pieces by
denji with the help of his team katana
man manages to win this fight and
capture the target but just as they're
about to escape makame intervenes by
apparently using the abilities of devil
she has contracts with she was able to
survive being shot by the assassins and
now uses her power to remotely kill
denji's kidnappers one by one each of
them get squashed like bugs by some
invisible force until the only ones left
standing are katana man and sawatari
from there a division iv agent called
kebeni steps in to save denji which is
redemption for the time she nearly
killed him inside the hotel
in the fallout from this ambush the few
surviving agents from divisions 1 2 and
three and then merge into division four
with makame being put in charge of
everyone one of her first actions in
charge is to strengthen the people they
have left hence why denji and power are
put under a savage training schedule
while aki gets stronger by making a
contract with the future devil once
their training is complete the new
division 4 then launched a revenge
attack against the enemy and during the
operation katana man is captured
sarathari is killed by her own devil and
public safety find over a kilogram of
gun devil flesh when this flesh is
combined with the pieces they already
have it finally starts moving towards
the gun devil's current location but
before we get into that denji and makima
go on a date following this experience
he swears to himself that he'll never
fall in love with anyone else but not
long afterwards he meets a new girl
called rhys reese is a student who works
at one of the local cafes and their
relationship progresses so quickly that
within a week she's asking him to leave
his job and run away with her sadly for
dengi the proposal wasn't exactly real
as it's revealed that she's a double
hybrid spy sent by the soviet union to
steal pagita
at the last second before she rips out
his heart chainsaw man is saved by the
shark fiend who's also a member of
special division iv and this forces rhys
to go about things a different way by
pulling the pin in her neck she
transforms into the bomb devil and goes
on to massacre a ridiculous amount of
people while chasing denji however with
the support of aki beaming the angel
devil chainsaw man is able to stop rhys
by trapping her underwater where she
naturally can't activate her explosions
in the end though because of how denji
feels about her he decides to let the
bomb devil escape instead of having her
locked up but within a day makima hunts
her down and seemingly finishes her off
now as a result of all the destruction
the new channels begin talking about
chainsaw man which is bad for public
safety as it lets the world know the
chainsaw devil is in japan this leads to
the german chinese and american
governments hiring assassins to go and
capture denji because for some reason no
one wants his power to be under
machima's control things then culminate
in tokyo with a battle between some of
the planet's strongest devil hunters
including kwangshi who's the devil
hybrid from china and santa claus from
the soviet union at one point during the
fight santa claus forms a contract with
the hell devil which sends denji and
everyone else around him to the
dimension where devils are first born it
doesn't take long for the group to then
be confronted in hell by the darkness
devil aka the oldest and arguably the
most powerful thing in the series
santa had a contract with this devil
that if she was able to deliver
chainsaw's heart to hell then it would
give her the power to kill macuma
explaining why back on earth santa now
receives a piece of dartness double
flesh
speaking of makima to save denji and the
others she uses her own method to travel
to hell and after a brief clash with the
darkness devil she narrowly manages to
teleport them back home following that
denji and quagsi form a temporary
alliance to successfully take down santa
claus and when everything is over makima
beheads the chinese assassin along with
her two remaining girlfriends in the
days after this power is so traumatized
from their fight with the darkness devil
that denji stays at home to take care of
her even though it means missing out on
a holiday with makama feeling guilty
about holding him back power then allows
denji to drink her blood and this will
be important later since power's blood
is special on account of her being the
blood fiend when it comes to aki having
witnessed how close they all were to
being killed in hell he decides to
withdraw division iv from any upcoming
fight against the gun devil even though
it's been his long-term ambition to get
revenge against the gun he cares about
denji and power too much to risk their
lives again but makima personally steps
in to deny his request for her own
personal reason she wants denji and
power to be involved in the mission and
she goes on to finally confirm the gun
devil's current location as it turns out
the gun has already been captured by
other nations with most of its body
being possessed by the chinese american
and soviet governments magama's plan is
therefore to infiltrate one of these
countries and capture the devil for
itself since whichever country has the
gone will have the upper hand against
everyone else
as the group come to terms with what
this all means aki then unexpectedly
receives a horrifying vision from the
future in which both he and power are
killed by chainsaw man previously the
future devil had predicted that aki
would die in the worst way possible but
now having seen a vision of that death
he wants to prevent his friends from
experiencing that specific future that's
why the next day he and angel pay a
visit to makama where he confesses that
he's willing to make any contract with
any devil if it means denji and power
can be safe makimo reacts to this
statement by forcing aki to then make a
contract with her as it's revealed that
her true identity is the control devil
as the name suggests the control devil
represents the fear of being conquered
or dominated and it gives her the
ability to control anyone she perceives
as weaker than herself she uses this
power to force both aki and angel to
make contracts with her against their
will and this gives her full control
over their bodies and minds
meanwhile on the other side of the
planet american spies learn about
makima's plan to capture the gun devil
causing the president to decide to kill
her once and for all to do this he
offers the gun one year from the
lifespan of all american citizens and in
exchange it agrees to eliminate the
control devil soon after this the gun
devil manifests on the shores of japan
and within five seconds it kills aki
makima and thousands of innocent
civilians however just like earlier in
the series the control devil is easily
brought back to life and this
resurrection is due to her contract with
the japanese prime minister the contract
stipulates that any time she's attacked
the damage she would have received is
redirected to random japanese people
essentially making her invincible as
long as there are people living in japan
following this she defeats the gun by
using the combined power of the future
devil angel devil and a few others and
with everyone now under her control she
puts the gun devil's spirit inside of
aki's corpse in that way aki becomes the
gun fiend and it's heavily implied that
machima sends him to attack denji this
puts chainsaw man in an impossible
situation where he had no choice but to
kill his friend to stop more innocent
people from dying and understandably the
whole incident had a serious impact on
his mental health
in chapter 86 denji vomits when he
remembers aki's death and he explains
the different ways his brain has been
messed up ever since it happened
gradually his thoughts get so bad that
when makame invites him to her house and
offers him any wish the one thing he
asked for is that she allows him to
become one of her pet dogs what this
means is that he wants to live the
simple life of a pet where you don't
really need to think for yourself and of
course the control devil agrees to this
for her own reasons using her new
authority over him makamir invites power
to her apartment and tells the energy in
advance that she's going to kill his
last remaining friend being the dog he
is chainsaw man skeptically goes along
with this even though his inner pachitta
is telling him not to and when he opens
the front door makima kills power
instantly for a while denji then goes
into shock unsure if what just happened
was even real but the truth is that it
was all part of the control devil's plan
from the beginning in order to explain
this plan we need to flash back over a
decade to a time before pachita and
denji even knew each other back then the
chainsaw devil was one of the most
powerful and in makkima's words pachita
was the devil that other devils feared
the most the reason for this was that he
had the unique ability to erase any
devil from existence with an example
being how he once ate the nuclear
weapons devil and now nuclear weapons
have vanished from the planet
a power like this could be used to
completely reshape the world and it's
why throughout the series so many people
have been trying to steal chainsaw's
heart when it comes to machima she knew
that denji's contract with pachita
required him to live a normal life so
our plan was to break that contract by
damaging him so much that he'd never be
able to live normally again she did this
by giving him everything he wanted in
life and then brutally destroying it in
the worst way possible to the point
where now he's so devastated he can't
even think for himself she also adds
salt to the wounds by revealing to
dengue that he was responsible for his
father's death which is a memory that
he'd been repressing the entire time
this info causes him to accept that he
doesn't deserve to live a normal life
essentially putting him under her
control
the next morning public safety send a
team of devil hunters to kill makama and
this team is led by denji's mentor
captain kishibe during the mission they
managed to hit the control devil with
rocket launchers submachine guns not to
mention they make a contract with the
hell devil to banish her to the
underworld however makima orders denji
to save her and from there he
transformed into the real chainsaw man
aka pachita's original form in this true
form he quickly tears apart the hell
devil while nakami describes takashibe
how she plans to make the world a better
place her ultimate aim is to use
perchita to erase things like war hunger
and death from existence but first she
has to defeat the true chainsaw devil in
a fight in order for him to be fully
under her control that's why after
everyone except kishibe is killed makima
goes to confront chainsaw man along with
rhys katanaman and several other devils
she controls
after a long fight she eventually uses
the power of the angel devil to nearly
finish him off but at the last second
power swoops in to save the day despite
being dead a small piece of her was
alive inside denji thanks to him
drinking her blood and with help from
pachita she's able to manifest in her
blood devil form the blood devil then
grabs denji and runs away and the two of
them have a final conversation before
she disappears during the talk power
reminds him that one day she'll be
reincarnated as the new blood devil
although she'll forget all the memory
she currently has for that reason she
forms a contract with energy to give him
a reason to keep living and the contract
says that in exchange for giving him
more of her blood he agrees to search
for power's reincarnation and somehow
make friends with her the next time they
see each other immediately following
this captain kishibe hides him in a safe
house so that makimo can't find them and
eventually they do come up with a plan
as bizarre as it sounds the plan starts
by denji ripping out his heart and then
the heart itself generates a brand new
body around it which is controlled by
pachita patchita then stands out in the
open which lures makima to his location
but because of the way he's dressed and
the way he acts she just assumes that
this is dengy meanwhile the real dendy
is hiding nearby waiting for machima to
let her guard down and he's able to
temporarily survive without a heart
thanks to the special blood he received
from the blood devil when the control
devil does eventually let her guard down
he catches her by surprise with this
special chainsaw made from power's blood
and it's relevant to mention that
throughout the series power was always
using blood to make different weapons
this chainsaw in particular has the
ability to slow down machima's
regeneration giving denji enough time to
slice her into tiny pieces
now because of her contract with the
japanese prime minister we know that
physical attacks aren't enough to
permanently kill the control devil but
luckily there is one strange way around
it in spite of everything that's
happened denji admits to himself that he
still likes makima and due to this lack
of hatred him eating her isn't
considered to be a physical attack by
eating her piece by piece denji believes
that he's killing makame with love and
through this method he is successful
with makima presumably being reborn in
hell just like every other devil in hell
it doesn't take long for makima to then
be killed again as she's reincarnated
back on earth in the form of a young
girl called nayuta nayuta was discovered
living in china and then kidnapped by
captain kishibe who now entrusts her to
denji the captain believes that denji is
the best person to race her because if
they give her to the japanese government
or any other government then she'll turn
out the same way she did the last time
the series ends with batista explaining
that makima's true goal was to have
something like a family which was hinted
at at a certain point but she was never
able to have that due to the nature of
her abilities that's why he asks denji
to try and make her dream a reality and
from that point forward they become a
family unit alongside all seven of
makima's dogs
the final page of chainsaw man reveals
that he's left public safety and is now
in high school which is something that
up until now he's never been able to do
denji not going to score was actually
the main reason why reese didn't kill
him when they first met because she
empathized with him and she also never
had the chance
anyhow my friends that is the summary
for part 1 of chainsaw man and be sure
to hit that sub button since part 2 of
the manga is scheduled to begin this
year thanks for watching as always and
until the next one peace out